25 year old right-hander making his 19th
start of the season 20th appearance
second career against the swinging a's
he's riding a two-game win streak even
up his record to six and six five
shutout innings three-hit ball and a
padres uniform begins right now for adam
frazier out there in left field
on the ground to first hospital trying
to start it second for one back to first
that's true
three six three on the double play james
caprilian makes a start for the
athletics and coming off a sixth innings
shutout baseball against the angels in
oakland 13th start for the young man
he's been outstanding adam frazier
leading it off from left field for the
padres
swings away drives one to left cannon is
there to make the catch for the first
down here in the bottom of the first
inning first a b for adam frazier is
over one down in the first four fernando
to left center that's going to get in
for a base hook for tatis
sliding over loriano he's got five
assists and safely
goes goes tatis
what a double fernando
so tatis takes third without two down
tatis down the line from third fastball
swung on and popped up on the infield
lowry is going to make the play in short
right center he's there in the rim of
the outfield grass to make the catch
it's a big pitch by caprilian
lowry remains its second one down to the
inning for seth brown
swinging the minutes and paddock picks
up his first k of the night that's a
good yakker right there for chris
paddock two down lowry at second base
still and brings up matt chapman
swing and a massive chapman strikes out
manic with back-to-back strikeouts works
his way around a lead-off double by
lowry tommy fan playing right field
and he went around chased the pitch that
was way inside that's the first
strikeout for james cabrillo that's a
great pitch everything a way away away
and then all of a sudden inside him fam
yeah
got him
grisham at 262 11 homers
strike three called outside corner so he
stayed with it
so a couple of strikeouts
for the designated hitter there is not
one and now here's caprilian
i forget that doesn't mean he can't hit
got a fastball lines the single to right
center nicely done by james caproe
something else for doug to cheer about a
good opportunity here the base is loaded
with one out and matt olson certainly
the guy you'd like to have up and he is
up
and the pitch is driven to center
grisham going back grisham near the wall
he's going to have just enough room he
makes the catch caprilian's going to
come in and score and the a's grab the
lead one nothing
thanks to the sac fly by matt olson he
didn't miss it by much cannon very
smartly going to third base
jed lowry up here it comes
fastball that stroke the other way
that's going to land for hit in front of
frazier in the score from third is canna
up the second is loriano it's two
nothing oakland jed lowry with an
opposite field rbi single here's sean
murphy
runner goes and the ball is dropped down
the first baseline fair ball over
hosper's head
loriano scores lowry's gonna turn on
third and stop and it's three to nothing
murphy
fighting that pitch off and he just did
a little lob wedge right over hosper's
head he'll take it it's an rbi double
kabrillian back to the mound with a
three-nothing lead as he faces victor
carratini little cutter on the inside
corner freezes carratini and he's going
to look him
dirty there it is
four straight strikeouts for cabrillo
two down here in the third and frazier
much better lineup
off the middle
and the throat
first hit padres uniform back up the
middle the beauty of the lineup for the
padres especially this point the infield
single you pop one here you're down by
one
hydra deep left field
fernando that's a two-round shot padres
the beauty of this lineup for the padres
as i mentioned you get a guy on adam
frazier with two outs legs one out
and fernando tatis jr does it with the
lumber and the potteries are within one
now tommy pham
and caps 3-2
best ball swing and a miss kept it away
and he's gone on strikes
it's a half a dozen for james
and now here comes trent grisham to the
plate
popped up
sanders easy play behind second base
he's got it and that will do it for the
padre two down mariano 90 feet away and
jed lowry standing in
line and caught by husband at first base
osmore reels it in in a hot shot by jed
lowry he's got nothing to show for it as
hasbro on the diving pick at first one
out runner and second tying run of that
and here is adam frazier
frazier lands it to the field
that's him for a hit
his second to padres uniform stopping at
third is karate and it's first in third
with one out in the padres fifth inning
base has loaded one out jake cronenworth
coming up
on the ground in the right corner
from third comes karate here comes
frazier throw to third to be late padres
take a 4-3 lead
jake
drives in the go ahead and run
first and third with still just one out
for machado
brown going back
three-run hot run for manny machado
[Applause]
bounced into a 6-4-3 dp
[Applause]
fly ball sky to left
frazier coming in on it
makes the catch
it ends the six chris paddock season
high on two strikes here to mark hannah
bloop to shallow right and fam coming in
to make the catch for the first out no
advance for camp
he fires it back in
loriano hits it hard to first hosmer's
got it he will win the race to the back
as taking third is kept with now two
outs in the seventh inning
one two is grounded right side corner to
the backhand
jace tingler knew what he was doing
brings in hill gets olson out so one out
sean murphy's gonna hit
[Applause]
that one deep to left field
and that babies go
murphy launches one his 13th home run of
the year to make it seven to four
a couple of rbis tonight for sean murphy
give them 47 on the air
with two outs in the ninth inning and
the padres on top seven to four
canna hits a fly ball to left field adam
frazier
he's under it
catches it padres win
mark molanco with a one two three ninth
inning
and the padres beat the oakland a's 7-4
[Applause]